sur le terrain les gens pensent que
qu'emmanuel macron peut représenter la
chance de la réforme pour la france
évidemment d'autres présentent plutôt on
va dire une vision un peu comment
dirais-je rêver de la réalité nous on
essaye de faire en sorte que la vie
change au quotidien pour les gens pas de
leur présenter le grand grand rêve
fantasmagorie lors la chance pour la
réforme est un paradoxe dans cette
élection les deux favoris emmanuel
macron et marine le pen en tout cas
d'après les sondages sont les deux
candidats qui est acquis on dit tout le
temps ils vont pas trouver de majorité
ça va être impossible et marine le pen
n'aura pas de majorité parce que son
mouvement est trop réduit emmanuel
macron va devoir composer avec des
composantes très disparates
comment comment vous allez faire demain
vous savez emmanuel macron on a dit
beaucoup de choses sur lui lorsque je
l'ait soutenu il y a un an et que je dis
qu'il est allé qu'il avait ses chances
pour devenir président de la république
personne ne me croyait
personne ne pensait qu'il ferait ce
chemin on a dit au départ c'est une
bulle après il a pas de programme et
cetera et cetera
et croyez moi on est en train de
préparer l'étape d'après c'est à dire la
majorité dans sa mise à jour à vie vous
assurer qu'il va effectivement avoir une
major ce que